moi je trouve très courageuse moi j'ai
toujours condamné la télé réalité alors
non pas parce que je suis une vieille
une vieille darron mais juste parce que
je trouve que c'est un milieu totalement
malsain et écoeurant et je vais vous
dire je condamne pas du tout les
candidats parce que moi je comprends
très bien que quand on est jeune après
tout on a envie de passer à la télé a
des rêves de gloire de notoriété
d'argent facile pourquoi pas mais moi
j'en veux énormément au prod qui
instrumentalisent les gamins qui vous
utilisent kivu format en fait vous êtes
de la soeur de prostitution moderne
télévision
c'est très dangereux pour les jeunes qui
regardent
comme vous pour la maison donc on
commence à se faire de la chirurgie à 20
ans on veut avoir des 56 on va avoir la
bouche comme ça donc je pense que c'est
dévastateur cet accord avec ce que dit
d'accord je suis hyper d'accord avec toi
géraldine en fait je trouve que c'est
pas ça à la télé si vous avez une sphère
la télé au final c'est passe à la télé
parce qu'on dit qu'effectivement tv
suroît phu yen mais plus oui oui plus
con parce que là il ya de la drogue et
de la ja du monde doit faire sa
[Applaudissements]
série aujourd'hui charles la raison le
nous deux fois il ya eu du racket de la
droite il y en a sept sous la vie
c'est pas tout
mais pas du tout
mais si abbas a dit positif dans les
idées mais ici ou chez laurent ruquier
one à la latéralité moi j'entends des
histoires deuxième sur la terrible
histoire de drogue incroyable oui c'est
très bien qu'il ya des choses qui vont
pas dans l'intérêt de tous défendre en
revanche je me fais du côté de la chaîne
et du programme il faut qu'ils aient un
programme après à sur ses deux
oreilles manga nam son près loribes
glory glory aujourd'hui toi ce que tu
conféraient
ses deux oreilles mais arrêtez c'est une
même pas qui c'est
c'est la soeur de béni
au kevin junan vraiment le tusson sairi
un début non alors moi pourquoi je suis
venu ici bon usage des 22 ans donc je
suis encore extrêmement jeune je suis
rentrée télé j'avais 20 ans déjà moi je
trouve qu'il ya un problème au niveau du
recrutement c'est on ne recherche pas
assez le passif des candidats avant de
les faire rentrer en télé moi mon
prétendants il a été accusé six mois
plus tard avant après avoir été en
prétendant de violences conjugales je
les notifier trois fois à la production
je vais virer moi même et six mois plus
tard il a été accusé de violence
conjugale donc déjà il ya un gros
problème sur les recherches en amont sur
les candidats deuxième chose le suivi
psychologique il y à 0 suivi
psychologique c'est à dire que tu fais
une interview avec quelqu'un tu poses
des questions une personne assez
manipulatrice elle dit ce qu'elle veut
de sa vie elle rentre en télé et ans et
a fait ce qu'elle veut il ya ni un suivi
psychologique après l'émission donc ça
veut dire on ne sait pas dans quel état
le candidat il sort s'il a envie ou pas
de refaire de la télé comment il se sent
et ensuite de les candidats donc
emblématique on a pas de suivi sur le
fait que tu aies un influenceur tu as le
devoir de faire attention à ce que tu
dis à ce que tu fais aux histoires que
tu vas peut provoquer une congère et pas
de le faire
non non des à dix mois des minimums je
dirais pas avant 25 ans de faire de la
télé parce qu'on n'est pas on n'a pas
assez d'expérience et sans rappel du
lycée à lui à une gamine de 18 ans qui
va les faire de la télé qu elles
s'exposent équivalent espèces en maillot
de bain cd lassant